hennala book TV we want to introduce you
to Kevin Young he's an author his book
bunk the rise of pokes is humbug
plagiarist
post facts and fake news comes out this
fall but this young before we go too far
into the book what do you do for a
living I'm the newest director of the
Schomburg Center in Harlem which is part
of the New York Public Library System as
you know and I've been there since
December it's been great we've had some
great announcements we just got the
James Baldwin papers which we announced
in April and we've just announced two
days ago the Sonny Rollins papers so
we're really excited to have those
archives come home to Harlem and be part
of what the cultural life there which
we've been there 92 years in Harlem in
the same corner code and 35th and Lenox
now Malcolm X Boulevard and we're really
happy to have those materials and those
essences come back to Harlem well you
say the Schomburg is part of the New
York Public Library System thank you
what's the focus the focus is of African
American and African Diaspora cultural
life from history to art to photographs
everything we have about 11 million
items relating to the Diaspora and
worldwide black culture I think that's
what makes us unique is both our age we
started in 1925 as an eat the Negro
Division of the New York Public Library
and a Carnegie Library which is still
standing and we got named a National
Historic Landmark in January so we're
really coming full circle I feel like
with these recent acquisitions which
really point to that long history
starting in the Harlem Renaissance
of documenting black life and black
culture and to the present day and both
Baldwin and Sonny Rollins were born in
Harlem were born right on that lived
around the corner and sort of to see
that arc and have them come home has
been really great
prior to joining the Schomburg what were
you doing I was a professor for 20 years
twelve of those at Emory University and
there I got archives as well so that's
how I sort of got an archive business
but I'm also a poet and a writer and I
had one previous non-fiction book called
the grey album and from that I really
started getting interested in the
subject of bunk which is hoaxes and
Liars in the sort of American history of
bakery where did the word bunk come it's
a great word it comes from politics
actually during arguing over the
Missouri Compromise in slavery
someone from Buncombe County which is in
North Carolina said oh I have to talk
more for the people of bunkum and people
then you start using welcome vu nco MBE
and then it became bunk um and then it
became bump as a way of sort of you know
political BS I guess is the best way so
the current term fake news is not really
anything new in our culture it's not I
really trace bunk starting in the 1830s
in Varnum and it's really sort of two
centuries of thinking about well how did
this come about is it particularly
American what does it have to do with
race and what does it have to do it now
and a lot of it in the 1830s starting
with PT Barnum was where I sort of begin
the book really comes about from new
media you know which sounds familiar
right and that new media sort of the
penny press press paper used to be a
little more expensive than they became a
penny and were sort of like a two sheet
they were pretty scandalous you know and
they were filled with hoaxes and filled
with bakery which often amused readers
you know there's a famous house on the
moon ho
where someone pretended they could see
like on the moon and that hoax really
spurred on I think a lot of what we're
seeing now is fake news but it as old as
1835 in your book you write that the
transformative advent of the penny press
most resembles the current change
Dempsey demonstrated if not caused by
the Internet yeah I mean I think the
Internet is a free press you know and
not in the media sense that you all are
in but in the sense of it's taking a
penny press to its extreme it's accessed
access access for folks and often
they're getting reflected back what they
like the penny press was very
competitive much like our news outlets
now and you see a lot of proliferation
of them and there's the similar thing on
the Internet
also similarly it's hard sometimes to
debunk as it were these things they kind
of circulate and circulate and that's
what's fascinating to me about whether
we're talking about the moon hoax or the
fake news of today and how hard it can
be to untangle ourselves from some of
these shared notions or notions that
some people have had become hard to
eradicate why do you start with pinky
Barney well I think Barnum's a
fascinating figure because Barnum is at
the center of American culture he is
helping to invent what we now think of
as pop culture he has entered pretty
much our notions of the circus he took
the sideshow which was always a thing
but made it kind of professional and
people would pay money and go to elegant
places to see these figures of dubious
origin you know that he would kind of
concoct and many of them also were
centered around race Barnum very much
when it was most famous early hope the
one that sort of got him going as a
successful showman was his display of
aluminum joy pep jo I see Hef and he was
pretended that she was George Washington
nursemaid she's a black woman he set to
161 years old you know and took her
around the Northeast and said you
come see George Washington's nursemaid
and this is a way of sort of connecting
to George Washington the father of our
country and people you know physically
examine her I mean is very troubling
mostly because then she dies and then he
has a medical theater where he died text
her in front of people
yeah I think it gets pretty intense but
he also then realized that you know
reveals oh she wasn't that old that's
also part of the hope you know the
revelation and that saw him I think a
lot about this idea of not only what you
could say and making almost patriotic to
believe in this Pope but also that
questioning the hopes are wondering
about it was also part of the hope you
know he was really great at making that
part of it and I think you see that kind
of now where the accusations of fake
news are just as important as the
revelations that they aren't fake you
know and that kind of circle and circus
as it were is part of Barnum's legacy
Trump signals a far more troubling
mindset one in which the truth isn't so
much absent or contested as it doesn't
matter yeah well I don't know if I'm
alone in saying that we're in an
interesting time where there are these
kind of questions about what is true but
there's almost predate our current
situation I think and the proliferation
of sort of conspiracy theory as news but
it's almost hard to eradicate and debunk
these kind of false notions um take
obamas citizenry what is that about
this kind of birtherism that happened
and I'm really interested tracing why do
we have that at all and obviously I
think it's about some of the same things
that Joyce has life and death were about
they're about great citizenry patriotism
who belongs who birth and death all the
kind of big cosmic things that I think
are part of our fabric as a nation but
they can be kind of evoked and
resurrected just from a kind of
suggestion and it's even hard now even
though a candidate Trump now president
had denied finally said oh that wasn't
true it's very hard to unsettle that and
a kind of notion of belonging and
selfhood about that attack on the birth
certificate of President Obama
represented so I'm really interested why
we do that and why we believe as much as
why we deceive why do we believe as much
as people like well some of it depends
on who the we is but some of it depends
on I think as people we're sort of want
to believe you know we're almost
programmed to and in the absence of an
answer that is complicated and sort of
maybe troubling we sometimes settle for
the easy answer it be easier to believe
that my discomfort comes from
some fact that it's being hidden from me
I think the difference from Barnum's day
to now is there was a notion that Barnum
had that I am an expert and also he
would you know trot out sort of fake
expert and but ultimately he gave the
power to people to decide I'm an expert
I can see that that looks like a mermaid
to me he had a famous fake mermaid or
that doesn't look like a mermaid that
was part of the interest in the show and
now there's a kind of assertion there is
no expert
you know the scientists don't matter
kind of climate change and maybe you
know there's a kind of really
fascinating denial of expertise at all
and that I think becomes even more
troubling and more of a difficult
position to be in bunk is the name of
the book it's coming out in November the
rise of hoaxes humbug plagiarists post
facts and fake news Kevin Young is the
author thanks for joining us thanks for
having me great the field